[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> All right. So the DOM captures the content
of the page. But we also need to know
how to display the actual page itself. And to
do that, we need to build a CSS Object Model.
>> Mm. And judging by its name, I guess it's similar to the DOM?
>> It's very close. Let's take a look. Ok. Let's say we've received the
following CSS. The first thing the browser
has to do is identify the correct tokens.
>> But there's no angle brackets here,
right?
>> Yeah. CSS has its own set of rules
for how to identify valid tokens. The details are not
that important. If you're curious, you can check out
the CSS specification link in the instructor notes. The important
part is that the parser would convert the tokens
to nodes, and in this case, the first would be
the body, with its font size property. Next, we would
get the paragraph node, and this is the important part.
It is a child of body because all of visible content is part of body.
>> Wait- Is that some CSS specification rule?
>> Yeah. Exactly.
>> Also note that the children of the
body node, inherit it's parent's styling rules of
sixteen pixel font size. This is what we
mean by cascading rules and cascading style sheets.
>> Interesting. So it's similar to, but not
quite the same as, the DOM construction because
CSS rules cascade down. Hm curious. Let's see I got
a style sheet with a lot of rules. Could we also
apply the same incremental processing trick, like we do with HTML,
to make the page display faster? That's a great question. Unfortunately,
we can't. We can't use a partial CSS tree. Let
me show you why. Let's say we just received the first
view bites of our CSS and it contains the two rules
we have here. So, we go ahead and build the CSS
object model. It's tempting to use this tree
to render a page, but there's a problem. Let's
say we now get the next chunk of CSS and it contains more rules. In this case,
we have the paragraph font weight normal. CSS allows us to redefine
and refine the style properties. This is perfectly valid. But notice
that this rule would allow us to change our CSS on tree.
And make the text in paragraph node display with normal weight.
>> So that's a gotcha. So, you're saying we can't really use a partial C-S-S on
tree. Because then it could lead us to
use the wrong styles when we render the page.
>> Exactly, the browser blocks page rendering, until it receives
and processes all of the CSS. CSS is render blocking.